Boa noite a todos é um prazer tê-los
aqui novamente para uma live vamos falar
de um assunto muito interessante que
hidrogênio molecular que é um assunto
muito novo então pode ser que tenham
perguntas que vocês façam que a gente
não vão ter não vai ter respostas assim
definitivas a
respeito Boa noite Eliseu Vanda Maria
Chaves eriete obrigado pelos comentários
dai Chaves Obrigado pela gentileza pelo
carinho pessoal por favor me deem um
feedback se vocês estão ouvindo bem o
áudio certo se tá bom o áudio boa noite
Rafael Boa noite Vanda tô aguardando aí
o feedback de vocês para dar
seguimento o áudio Tá bom
Rafael ótimo
Obrigado Alexandre Peres Rafael pelos
comentários bem Hoje nós vamos falar
sobre o poder do hidrogênio molecular e
os benefícios para saúde além eu vou
tentar ir respondendo na pergunta de
vocês ao longo da Live Então em vez de
ficar falando durante meia
hora eu vou falar aí 10 15 minutos
responder algumas perguntas e
continuar falando sobre o
tema então o hidrogênio molecular é uma
substância que tem despertado bastante
interesse na comunidade científica Os
Pioneiros são
japoneses devido suas propriedades e
potencial teraputico ele é constituo
pelo elemento mais leve da Tabela
Periódica também o mais simples e ele é
fundamental para vida todos nós sabemos
que a maior parte das moléculas T
hidrogênio na sua composição
está presente na composição de quase
todas as moléculas
orgânicas então a sua simplicidade e
leveza conferem a ele a capacidade de
atravessar Barreiras biológicas como a
membrana celular a barreira
hematoencefálica ou hematol
licca alcançando o núcleo das células e
as mitocôndrias onde pode exercer
efeitos benéficos em 2020 foi publicado
um livro interessante tema deixa Deixa
eu só tirar o barulhinho do WhatsApp tá
incomodando um pouco
aqui ok Pronto já tirei o
barulhinho então Voltando ao assunto em
2020 foi publicado um livro chamado
hidrogênio molecular para medicina
desculpa que eu tô com garganta um
pouquinho costando hoje um pouquinho
irritada então foi publicado esse livro
hidrogênio molecular para medicina pela
Editora Springer Nature uma obra
Pioneira de um autor japonês o yufu Kai
que mergulha no campo emergente da
Medicina do hidrogênio molecular é um
testemunho do potencial dessa molécula
na Esfera médica o Yu fukai é um
professor emérito da Universidade de
chuo em Tóquio e ele tem uma extensa
experiência em física química ciência
doos materiais e ciênci da Terra em
geral então ele escreveu essa obra para
fornecer um guia abrangente sobre os
efeitos terapêuticos e possíveis
aplicações médicas do hidrogênio
molecular Então esse livro surge de uma
descoberta científica que foi relatada
em 2007 Então os pesquisadores japoneses
tiveram um grande breakthrough tiveram
aí uma sequência de descobertas a partir
de
2007 que eles observaram em cobaias né
que ainda relação de gás hidrogênio
reduzia significativamente as espécies
reativas né os radicais livres e esta
descobertas abriram caminho para mais
pesquisas e começou a se fazer também
ensaios clínicos e humanos então É bem
recente quer dizer que começou em 2007
até 2007 Se achava que o hidrogênio era
uma molécula inerte não tinha grandes
efeitos nos seres
humanos então esses saios clínicos vem
apresentando
resultados
promissores em várias condições de saúde
né ele pode tratar várias doenças
diferentes esse trabalho do fukar ele é
particularmente significativo porque ele
compila e apresenta essas descobertas
tanto paraa comunidade científica para
também o público muitos ainda permanecem
desinformados so potencial médico do
hidrogênio
molecular Então vamos começar
respondendo algumas
perguntas
É verdade que o hidrogênio molecular
atua em mais de 175 doenças sim ele atua
em praticamente quase todas as doenças
crônicas nós vamos falar isso ao longo
da Live tem efeito colateral a princípio
não tá tem alguns relatos anedóticos de
pessoas que tiveram náusea usando
hidrogênio que tiveram alguns sintomas
mas não ficou muito claro
eh hipoglicemia também foi relatada em
caso mas não ficou claro que esse efeito
colateral tenha sido por causa do
hidrogênio tem um estudo na universidade
de Pittsburg que o consumo diário de
água hidrogenada por seis semanas não
teve efeitos colaterais em 49 pacientes
com câncer de pulmão em estágio inicial
Tá e pelo contrário o hidrogênio
preveniu o aumento dos níveis de espécie
reativa ou seja os radicais
livres outro estudo com indivíduos
saudáveis não encontrou diferenças
significativas nos valores do sangue
hematológicos nos grupos Placebo ou que
usou o hidrogênio molecular tá Então
essa é
praticamente zero de efeitos
colaterais hidrogênio molecular tem
alguma semelhança com ozônio terapia não
ozônio é um agente oxidante e o
hidrogênio é um agente antioxidante O
que acontece no caso do ozônio é se você
usar Se você usar uma dose relativamente
baixa até 20 micra mais ou menos
eh você vai ter um efeito rebote
antioxidante mas o ozônio por si só ele
é oxidante e o organismo Se não receber
ozônio demais ele vai ter uma resposta
adaptativa antioxidante tá então são
moléculas diferentes com ações
diferentes algum suplemento fortalece a
ação do hidrogênio não nenhum suplemento
até hoje tem essa propriedade pelo menos
que foi descoberta até o momento água
com hidrogênio é melhor do que água
mineral não eh quer dizer é melhor sim
porque tem ação antioxidante tá então se
você for utilizar como remédio sim o
água com hidrogênio ela ela é melhor
pelos efeitos
antioxidantes Obrigado pelo comentário
carinhoso Maria e Obrigado também pelo
comentário carinhoso
ilete
então hidrogênio molecular elimina
radicais livres sim
elimina Então nós vamos falar disso
agora vamos continuar a falar do
tema então o livro que o yuf Kai
publicou ele guia o leitor através de
uma série de estudos ensaios clínicos e
discussões teóricas e apresenta
meticulosamente as evidências dos
efeitos do hidrogênio em várias
condições e doenças né incluindo o
potencial para aliviar sintomas e
melhorar resultados em distúrbios que
vão desde a cim metabólica inflamação
até doenças
neurodegenerativas então respondendo a
pergunta do Eliseu estudos tem
demonstrado que o hidrogênio molecular
atua como antioxidante
seletivo por seletivo porque ele vai
neutralizar radicais livres específicos
como oila e o peroxinitrito que são
altamente reativos e podem causar danos
significativos às células e também ao
DNA ao mesmo tempo o hidrogênio não
interfere com radicais livres que
desempenham papéis importantes em
processos fisiológicos já falei isso em
vários vídeos mas muitos de vocês
provavelmente não sabem mas os radicais
livres têm função biológica os radicais
L são utilizados pela célula de defesa
como instrumento para matar os
microorganismos então é preciso ter um
pouco de Radical Livre no corpo então
hidrogênio é o único antioxidante que
foi descoberto até hoje que ele não
interfere com esses radicais livres que
são dos processos
fisiológicos da função imune da
sinalização celular Então essa
seletividade é muito valiosa e é uma das
razões pelas quais o hidrogênio é
considerado um
antioxidante muito promissor com
potencial para proteger o organismo sem
perturbar o equilíbrio oxidativo nós
precisamos paraa saúde tá
então nos últimos 20 anos foi muito
falado do Poder dos antioxidantes e dos
últimos 5 anos para cá tem sido revisto
essa questão da antioxidação porque se
você faz uma antioxidação exagerada
também não é bom pro organismo então o
hidrogênio ele entra bem aí nessa
questão s sendo um antioxidante
seletivo e já aproveitando para
responder essa dúvida aqui o RP a
potência de oxidantes o RP é uma medida
em
milivolt de quanto uma substância pode
ser oxidativa se for um RP positivo ou
quanto que ela é uma substância redutora
que é um RP negativo então RP positivo é
uma substância que oxida o RP negativo é
uma substância que tira a oxidação que é
ao contrário disso chama-se redução
Então quando você vê um gerador de
hidrogênio aqueles copios que geram
hidrogênio na água você vai que ter vai
ter um RP negativo porque eles são
agentes sedutores são agentes
antioxidantes além das suas propriedades
antioxidantes o hidrogênio molecular tem
efeitos antiinflamatórios eh bem
interessantes contribuindo paraa
modulação de vários processos
inflamatórios isso é particularmente
relevante pois a inflamação crônica está
associada a uma variedade de doenças
incluindo condições cardiovasculares
asma Artrite reumatoide então a
capacidade do hidrogênio de influenciar
positivamente esse processo tem então um
amplo espectro de aplicações
terapêuticas que justifica o crescente
interesse nesse tema na pesquisa e
desenvolvimento Eu tenho uns slides aqui
para mostrar para
vocês Deixa eu ver essa aqui página que
eu tô primeiro slide aqui
[Música]
né Então aqui tem um resuminho do que eu
falei até agora aqui certo na tela de
vocês mas vamos continuar aqui acho que
eu vou colocar eu também
junto pronto vou deixar assim não melhor
deixar assim
pronto então nós sabemos que a
importância do hidrogênio pra vida e
ável a sua presença é essencial em
processos biológicos fundamentais a
ligação de hidrogênio é crucial paraa
estrutura e função de várias moléculas
biológicas incluindo o próprio DNA e as
proteínas e o hidrogênio também é um
componente chave na produção de ATP que
é a molécula de energia a principal
molécula de armazenamento de energia com
a evolução da pesquisa o hidrogênio
molecular está sendo reconhecido não
apenas como um componente Vital da
bioquímica Mas também como agente
terapêutico potencial para impactar
muito a saúde
humana Vamos responder mais uma pergunta
aqui não Eliseu o hidrogênio molecular
não é a única molécula que tira
hidroxila vários outos vários outros
antioxidantes com o binol que você
mencionou aqui tem essa propriedade mas
a maioria dos antioxidantes vai atuar no
Radical superóxido e também no peróxido
hidrogênio Tá mas existe sim outros
antioxidantes que conseguem eliminar a
hidroxila Boa noite
Vanda o hidrogênio molecular pode ajudar
no controle ou melhora da éa da
esclerose lateral motr sim seria um
excelente recurso de suporte Nunca Vou
sugerir a vocês que só utilizem o
hidrogênio molecular sozinho para
qualquer doença mas ele seria muito
interessante para ajudar a controlar a
inflamação da esclerose lateral
neotrópica então o hidrogênio molecular
tem uma série de benefícios paraa saúde
e tem sido cada vez mais suportado cada
vez mais confirmado por pesquisas
científicas entre as propriedades mais
notáveis é a que eu já falei a
capacidade antioxidante
seletiva especialmente contra o radical
hidroxila e o peroxinitrito
isso vai proteger o DNA e as células
contra danos
oxidativos que vai evitar as mutações
desenvolvimento de doenças crônicas a a
água rica em hidrogênio por exemplo é
altamente eficaz em reduzir o estresse
oxidativo em pacientes com Artrite
reumatoide que é uma doença inflamatória
que nós sabemos que pode causar
destruição progressiva das articulações
e aumentar o risco de doenças
cardiovasculares tem uns efeitos que eu
já comentei antiinflamatórios que são
bem
significativos estudos indicam que o
hidrogênio pode suprimir a ativação de
vias inflamatórias como é o caso da FK
Beta também os mediadores tnf Alfa que é
o fator de necros tumoral alfa e a forma
oxidativa a forma de Radical Livre do
óxido nítrico óxido nítrico é um
mediador importante para células para
vaso dilatação Mas ele tem um primo
irmão aí que é um Radical Livre que tem
que ser removido quando tá em excesso
Então essa ação
antiinflamatória É bem interessante para
qualquer doença crônica falei da Artrite
reumatoide mas comentei aqui respondendo
a pergunta da esclerose lateral meot
trófica serve para asma também o
hidrogênio
inalado doenças
cardiovasculares tem também vários
efeitos neuroprotetores vou até mudar o
slide
aqui então os efeitos neuroprotetores
também são Campo promissor de estudo por
exemplo já estão sendo utilizados as
soluções Salinas ricas em
hidrogênio que pode ser feita por v
endovenosa e tem prevenido a
neuroinflamação o stresse
oxidativo no momento foi feito em
modelos animais e pode resultar em
melhorias da disfunção da memória então
a capacidade do hidrogênio de atravessar
a barreira hematoencefálica ou hematol
licca ajuda a proteger as células
cerebrais que torna ele é um candidato
potencial pro tratamento de várias
doenças
neurodegenerativas
e para melhorar a
cognição também tem sido utilizado para
melhoria do desempenho
Atlético Então essa modalidade explora
as propriedades antioxidantes
antiinflamatórias e alcalinizantes que o
hidrogênio tem e é bem interessante bem
benéfico para atletas que são submetidos
a exercícios intensos e competições
estudos indicam que a hidratação com
água rica em hidrogênio antes do
exercício
pode reduzir o qu os níveis de lactato
no sangue que em excesso dá muita dor né
da câimbra
então nós sabemos que o lactato é um
subproduto do metabolismo muscular
Quando você vai pra academia faz
musculação e volta dolorida por causa do
ácido lático do
lactato então o hidrogênio reduz isso
daí então por isso tá sendo muito
utilizado para medicina
esportiva Além disso o hidrogênio tem o
potencial de atenuar a dose
muscular comum em atividades físicas de
alta
intensidade ão melhorando o desempenho
desses atletas e a função contrátil dos
músculos aumentando também a produção de
ATP e a aplicação do hidrogênio na
medicina esportiva também não se limita
apenas na prevenção de fadiga ou a
melhoria dos desempenho também pode ser
utilizado para pro tratamento de lesões
como em Tor
porque ele acelera a recuperação dos
tecidos mores danificados reduz a
inflamação e promove uma recuperação
mais rápida Então isso é particularmente
relevante pros entorses paraas extensões
pras rupturas de ligamentos e concussões
onde uma rápida intervenção pode
significar uma diferença substancial no
tempo de recuperação e na qualidade do
retorno né do praticante esportista as
atividades Então se tem sido utilizada a
inalação com gás
hidrogênio atletas que utilizam essa
técnica relatam não apenas uma
recuperação mais rápida após os
exercícios mas também uma melhora
significativa na resistência e na
capacidade de treinar com mais
frequência então a terapia com
hidrogênio surge como uma ferramenta
valiosa para treinadores fisioterapeutas
e médicos esportivos
que querem que seus atletas tenham uma
performance mais alta possível
Ah tem uma pergunta aqui pode
usar na culinária Que eu saiba não
Eliseu não tô sabendo
disso Obrigado pelo
comentário bem Adriano então fica até o
final que você vai aprender todos os
benefícios não saia antes do final
pessoal ajudem esse canal e divulguem
essa Live os seus contatos divulguem
paraos seus amigos pros seus familiares
porque a plataforma tem boicotado esse
canal por causa de coisas que eu falei
de TR anos para cá e vocês sabem o que
que aconteceu 3 anos atrás então ajudem
o canal a voltar a ter relevância um
canal relativamente grande com 700.000
inscritos e que grande maioria dos
inscritos não são avisados de novos
vídeos e a gente tem tido aí um problema
de alcance então ajude esse canal se
você gosta do
conteúdo divulgue essa Live divulgue
outros vídeos do canal pros seus
contatos nas redes sociais ajuda esse
canal a ganhar
relevância tem tanta bobagem no YouTube
que tem muito mais relevância vamos
ajudar a espalhar a palavra a espalhar
né informações de alta qualidade que vai
revolucionar a vida de muitas
pessoas profor de saber se o hidrogênio
molecular substitui todos os outros
elementos que são
antiinflamatórios eu não chegaria tanto
Marcelo Mas você pode utilizar
sim e por que substituir por por que não
associar você pode utilizar o hidrogênio
na fórmula de água hidrogenada e pode
também usar uma curcumina uma bosé
serrata uma garra do diabo né usar um
outro antiinflamatório natural também né
porque usar só um
h não você vai
tomar quantidade de água hidrogenada 1/3
mais ou menos da quantidade de água que
você bebe ao longo do
dia não se tem essa informação Clara
ainda Eliseu porém Tudo indica que sim
porque ele se ele redu o stress
oxidativo que é os principais mecanismo
no envelhecimento então poderia se você
utilizar durante vários anos poderia ter
Teoricamente reduzir retardar o
envelhecimento Boa noite S Obrigado pelo
comentário
eh Já respondi isso
aqui sim sad poderia ser bom para essa
situação que você colocou
aí não Eliseu não faz parte do protocolo
recode o que faz mais parte é o uso de
oxigênio
eh em terapia
hiperbárica o hidrogênio molecular ele
não tem nenhuma contraindicação na
gravidez não ele é totalmente
seguro bem vamos continuar
aqui outros benefícios do hidrogênio
molecular são a melhoria da função
mitocondrial a promoção da Saúde
intestinal renal e hepática E além disso
ele tem demonstrado ser útil na
cicatrização de feridas na proteção
contra danos induzidos por radiação e na
melhoria da Saúde da pele então sua
aplicação em condições como diabetes
síndrome metabólica é notável com
relatos de redução nos níveis de glicos
então ele ajuda a baixar o açúcar do
sangue também reduzir a insulina e os
triglicérides e a segurança é um ponto
forte como eu falei ele não é tóxico
mesmo em altas concentrações mas o
hidrogênio tem um detalhe aí ele não é
tóxico Mas ele é muito difícil de você
manusear
eh em altas concentrações quando você
tira ele de um cilindro de alta pressão
porque ele em contato com o oxigênio ele
pode explodir ele pode pegar fogo então
o problema do hidrogênio não é dentro do
organismo humano é manusear
e cilindros com alta de hidrogênio na
forma líquida Então esse que é o
problema que na prática atrapalha o
manuseio do hidrogênio e o único
subproduto no organismo é a água né
então ele não tem nenhuma
contraindicação Clara até o momento
então nós sabemos que ele tem um vasto
potencial
terapêutico com o benefício que abrange
da parte que já nós falamos antioxidante
antiinflamatória
neuroprotetora melhoria da saúde geral
então todos vocês Eu recomendo que de
maneira preventiva comprem lá os
geradores de hidrogênio por Hidrólise
que você pode comprar no mercado livre
pode comprar no AliExpress compre uma
com um RP negativo alto isso vale muito
a pena para prevenir
doenças então hidrogênio é uma
ferramenta valiosa e versátil na busca
por tratamentos mais eficazes e menos
invasivos vamos falar um pouquinho sobre
o tratamento do Câncer o hidrogênio
molecular ele tem emergido como
potencial aliado no tratamento do Câncer
porque Ele oferece esperança para a
melhoria de qualidade de vida dos
pacientes controle da progressão da
doença porque estudos recentes indicam
que o hidrogênio Tem sim atividades
antitumorais ele pode suprimir a
proliferação de células tronco
cancerígenas isso é uma coisa muito
importante porque até quimioterapia tem
dificuldade de destruir célula tronco
cancerígena também tem a propriedade de
inibir angiogênese que aquela formação
dos vasos
eh que os tumores forçam o organismo a
produzir para alimentar os
tumores então inibir angiogênese
essencial para evitar o crescimento
moral então pesquisas na China mostraram
que a inalação de hidrogênio molecular
por se semanas reduziu
significativamente o crescimento de
tumores em anim mais diminuindo o volume
médio do tumor e a expressão de
marcadores
Associados angiogênese então além do
efeito direto sobre as células tumorais
o hidrogênio molecular tem o efeito de
Minimizar efeitos colaterais dos
tratamentos contra o câncer
quimioterapia radioterapia que
frequentemente resultam em um aumento do
estress oxidativo e também de danos à
células saudáveis então o hidrogênio Vai
tanto efeito antitumoral quanto ela vai
proteger contra os efeitos colaterais da
químio e da
Rádio Então como ele é um antioxidante
seletivo ele protege as células não
cancerosas sem interferir na eficácia
dos tratamentos
quimioterápicos ou
radioterápicos então o hidrogênio vai
ajudar na redução da Fadiga da insônia
da anorexia e da dor que são sintomas
comuns que afetam muito a qualidade de
vida dos pacientes
oncológicos um estudo de acompanhamento
com 82 pacientes com câncer avançado que
foram tratados com inalação de
hidrogênio molecular houve relatos de
melhoras significativas de sintomas como
fadiga e dor após quatro semanas de
tratamento E além disso observou-se uma
melhora na na aptidão física uma parcela
dos pacientes especialmente aqueles que
tinham câncer de pulmão a taxa de
controle da doença foi maior em
pacientes estágio 3 do que no Estágio 4
indicando né que seria esperado que o
hidrogênio pode ser mais eficaz em
estágios menos
avançados bem vamos para mais
perguntas muita gente dando boa noite
boa noite Leopoldino Borges querido pass
lá de
Brasília Boa noite Regina
Evanete
Regina tá perguntando se no rio tem
médicos que trabalham com hidrogênio com
certeza é só você procurar Regina Eu só
não vou indicar
aqui Eliseu tá perguntou de que maneira
o hidrogênio molecular ajuda no
tratamento para diabetes ele tem efeito
antiglicante tá ele reduz o nível de
açúcar no sangue e de insulina o
mecanismo exato ainda não é bem
compreendido sim o hidrogênio ele é
relativamente simples de gerar por
eletrólise você compra um gerador hoje
tem muitos geradores aí portáteis você
compra no Mercado Livre compra no
AliExpress eu não vou indicar nenhum
vendedor específico aqui mas é fácil de
achar só procure alguém que tenha boa
reputação e que o o potencial RP seja
bem baixo
tá eu não li nada a respeito desse
assunto específico Carla mas a tendência
que ajude sim
tá tem a parte que você faz em
consultório com hidrogenia na lado que
não dá para fazer em casa e tem a parte
que você faz em casa que é o hidrogênio
diluído na água eh que o gerador de
hidrogênio você compra aí como eu
comentei no
sites sim Regina pode ajudar no fã
positivo não tem problema Regina eu tô
falando tudo que eu tô falando
tá tudo que tá no slide eu tô falando
muito mais então se você não consegue
ler depois você pega o vídeo gravado e
coloca no computador numa tela maior e
você consegue ler tá bom porque também é
não dá para fazer milagre aqui porque os
slides eh são feitos para telas grandes
não para celular
né o hidrogênio pode curar problemas do
coração e circulação pode ajudar a curar
tá não usaria isso isoladamente para
isso Sei lá Eliseu aí você tá tá fazendo
uma pergunta que tem que fazer umas
contas matemáticas aí
e mas com certeza vai ser um efeito
antioxidante muito maior do que qualquer
coisa que você possa comer né por via
oral olha um depoimento aqui do almo
temho feito sessões de hidrogênio noto
muita disposição imediata alteração
significativa no olfato e
Paladar com certeza deve ter uso na
odontologia deve
ajudar na cicatrização de cirurgias
odontológicas deve ajudar a melhorar aí
a o efeito do sistema imune sobre a
boca abraço aí Angélica de Campo Grande
Boa
noite eu não conheço essa culinária
molecular Cláudia se depois se você
tiver aí a fonte disso pra gente poder
dar uma olhada nas minhas pesquisas eu
não achei
isso tem grande capacidade sim de limpar
o sangue é um termo muito leivo né mas
tem grande capacidade como eu falei
antioxidante
antiinflamatória e vai ajudar o detox de
uma maneira Indireta não
diretamente
hidrogênio pode se aplicar na pele não
você pode aplicar água hidrogenada na
pele né Se tiver uma ferida vai ajudar a
cicatrizar a
ferida a Sandra comentando que trabalha
com hidrogênio molecular nos
pacientes quiser fazer aí algum
comentário a mais quiser dar mais uma
informação para enriquecer essa Live
fica à
vontade função renal seria melhoria da
esp renal sem diálise sim melhora da
função renal com ou sem insf renal
né tem efeito para ajudar a reduzir a
ência renal melhorar a função renal de
modo
geral não o a câmera hiperbárica João é
oxigênio em alta pressão é muito bom
também mas tem outros princípios não é
igual o hidrogênio molecular Você pode
até fazer por exemplo um dia o oxigênio
em câmera hiperbárica ou ozônio no outro
dia você pode fazer o hidrogênio fazer
em dias separados que eles têm funções
diferentes Já respondi isso aqui estava
está gravado aí na
Live o jeito fácil de usar é você
comprar um gerador de
hidrogênio são os copinhos ou garrafas
que você compra na internet tá eles e
fazem eletrólise na água e gera
hidrogênio que fica diluo na
água não tem essa contraindicação
Tamara Sim pode ser aplicado nos ouvidos
também e vamos continuar
aqui então os resultados que eu falei
sobre o uso do hidrogênio no tratamento
oncológico é bem promissor pode ser um
complemento valioso aos tratamentos
oncol os existentes portanto é
importante ressaltar a necessidade de
mais pesquisas e Estudos clínicos porque
tem pouc estudos clínicos ainda para
validar esses achados estabelecer
Protocolos de tratamentos Seguros
eficazes então a gente sabe que essa
integração do hidrogênio molecular na
prática Clínica pode representar um
avanço significativo na terapia do
câncer mas que a gente tem que ter mais
informação mais dado para que a
comunidade científica e médica possa
confiar
no uso desse
elemento Então vamos reforçar e dar mais
detalhes de um ponto que eu já abordei
várias vezes aqui que é fundamental nós
falarmos um pouco mais que é a ação
antioxidante seletiva do hidrogênio ele
vai neutralizar seletivamente os
radicais livres
específicos que são particularmente
prejudiciais à células sem afetar os
radicais livres importantes pros
processos fisiológicos
então entre os radicais livres nós temos
um que é particularmente danoso que é o
hidroxila que é o oh
mais ele é capaz de causar lesões
celulares irreparáveis e contribuir para
o processo de envelhecimento e
desenvolvimento de várias doenças então
o hidrogênio reage com o radical
hidroxila transformando em água e é
completamente inofensivo pro corpo essa
água então essa reação não apenas impede
dano oxidativo mas também contribui
paraa
hidratação
molecular a hidratação
celular já foi falado que o tamanho
extremamente pequeno das moléculas de
hidrogênio permite que elas se difundam
de maneira rápida pelas membranas
celulares vai alcançar locais
inacessíveis para a maioria dos
antioxidantes vai chegar no interior das
mitocôndrias com facilidade onde pode
exercer efeit protetores contra o
estresse oxidativo
mitocondrial foi falado também que o
hidrogênio tem essa facilidade de
atravessar a barreira hematoencefálica e
oferece então uma proteção antioxidante
ao tecido cerebral que é particularmente
vulnerável ao dano
oxidativo então hidrogênio também tem
funções interessantes e benéficas no
mecanismo de sinalização celular ele
pode modular a expressão gênica e ativar
sinais de vias de sinalização que
aumenta a produção endógena de
antioxidantes do próprio corpo então
além dele produzir o si só antioxidação
ele vai ajudar a produzir os
antioxidantes naturais endógenos como é
o caso dos peróxidos mutase e a glota
peroxidase e essa ativação do hidrogênio
molecular ele ocorre através do sistema
nrf2 que é
ap1 que é um regulador chave na resposta
antioxidante celular que é o ser
estimulado pelo hidrogênio e promove a
expressão de genes que codificam enzimas
antioxidantes e moléculas
protetoras além dele ser um agente
redutor de radicais livres ele também
atua como modulador biológico que pode
influenciar positivamente a homeostase
edox e a resposta antioxidante do
organismo e então ele se torna um
candidato promissor paraa prevenção e
tratamento de várias doenças associadas
ao estresse oxidativo Então vamos falar
um pouquinho mais sobre metabolismo do
açúcar e das gorduras que eu falei
rapidamente Mas vamos elaborar mais esse
tema então a água enriquecida com
hidrogênio ela vai reduzir a glicose do
sangue vai melhorar o metabolismo dos
lipídeos E também o metabolismo
glicídico e ISO Vai representar um
excelente tratamento e prevenção de
dúbios metabólicos como é o caso do tipo
2 e obesidade então alguns estudos
indicam que a ingestão de água pura HR
ogio pode influenciar positivamente o
metabolismo ao induzir expressão do
fator de crescimento de fibroblastos 21
que é o fgf 21 no fígado essa é uma
proteína que desempenha um papel crucial
na regulação do gasto energético na
proteção contra a obesidade induzida por
dietas ricas em calorias então tem esse
efeito no
fgf21 não se sabe se é o único efeito
que o hidrogênio tem na questão aí da
redução do açúcar do
sangue mas é fato que o
fgf21 ele está envolvido na redução dos
níveis de glicose e trigliceridos no
sangue então hidrogênio pode ajudar a
melhorar esse perfil tanto de gorduras
quanto de glicose vamos para mais
perguntas
eh os três Regina tanto preventivo
quanto curativo quanto paliativo
funciona dos três
jeitos há aparelhos que podem
simultaneamente emitir hidrogênio e
gerar água hidrogenada sim mas é é o
princípio é esse Você vai eh produzir
hidrogênio através da eletrólise e esse
hidrogênio vai ficar diluído na água né
Não sei se vou Você quis dizer outra
coisa mas esse é o princípio de todos os
aparelhos obrigado gilan pelo carinho
viu um abraço para
você
ah Alexandre Pest meu colega da pós do
La Ribeiro tá fazendo uma perguntinha
aqui
[Música]
Ahã eu não entendi Exatamente esse
assunto que você perguntou mas eu não
vou nem colocar na tela por medo de
termos problemas aí com a o alcance da
Live viu Alexandre você vai me perdoar
mas o YouTube tá muito
complicado Marcelo tomo água saturada
com hidrogênio molecular em jejum e a
sensação de saciedade em
imediato
eh uma vez inalado o hidrogênio
molecular Qual o tempo que ele permanece
nos pulmões ele vai difundir quase que
imediatamente pelas membranas então ele
vai atingir o sangue muito rapidamente
viu Paulo questão de segundos ele vai
atingir eh o sangue e o corpo inteiro
vai depender aí da do tamanho da pessoa
e da pressão arterial mas questão de
minutos vai atingir o corpo
inteiro sim tem uma função
hepatoprotetora sim tá no hidrogênio
inclusive vamos falar um pouco desse
assunto agora aqui então a suplementação
com água rica em hidrogênio tem sido sim
associado à redução de estress oxidativo
no fígado a diminuição da esteatose
hepática que é a gordura do
fígado e é um fator de risco nós sabemos
que esse acúmulo de gordura no fígado é
um fator de risco para várias outras
doenças inclusive para
câncer
a água rica hidrogênio pode suprimir o
ganho de peso corporal e reduzir os
níveis de glicose triglicerides no
sangue como eu
falei o que é benéfico paraa manutenção
de um peso
saudável para prevenção de complicações
cardiovasculares Então os mecanismos
exatos que o hidrogênio tem como eu
falei pro nosso querido aí
Eliseu não estão totalmente definidos
como é que baixa o açúcar do sangue como
é que baixa o triglicérides estão sendo
ainda investigados esses efeitos eu
falei do
fgf21 Mas isso é só um detalhezinho isso
sozinho não explicaria então mais
estudos sugerem que hidrogênio pode
atuar como sinalizador molecular
estimulando o metabolismo energético e
promovendo a utilização de ácidos gros e
glicose paraa produção de
energia isso é bem relevante né para
pessoas doentes doenças crônicas e
atletas que pode eh por cont ibu muito
pra melhora de performance pra
recuperação pós exercício e pra
recuperação dessas
doenças se eu conheço a Beta
criptoxantina Conheço sim falou que deu
para os seus pacientes isso e também
lactoba os 40 bilhões cas [ __ ] tá eu
conheço essa história desde a época da
pos Ribeiro ele falava disso daí para
tratamento de câncer de
bexiga
já comentei isso aqui Fábio no
AliExpress no Mercado Livre você vai
encontrar esses geradores de hidrogênio
em
casa a Sandra dizendo uso muito para
desinflamar bacana
Sand o hidrogênio molecular é um
carreador de oxigênio celular não ele
não é um carreador de oxigênio ele é um
agente
antioxidante
seletivo tá então El não vai aumentar
exatamente o o carreamento de
oxigênio ó César tá falando que Esses
aparelhos menores são bons se for de um
bom fornecedor um bom fabricante
são Eliseu não tem assim uma prova
inequívoca que a água hidrogenada tire
agrotóxicos dos alimentos mas eu acho
que vale a pena sim faz essa
lavagem Obrigado Adriana aí pelos
comentários Sem dúvida jaz concordo
plenamente com você só que a questão do
ozônio é mais complicada porque o
Conselho Federal de Medicina durante
muitos anos se colocou numa posição
muito firme contra o ozônio né isso não
acontece até o momento com o hidrogênio
e nem tem razão de ser eu acho que o
drogen vai ser muito mais fácil adoção
pelas pessoas porque não existe essa
resistência como tem com o ozônio pelo
menos que eu não tenho
identificado de forma direta não Regina
mas de forma indireta pode ajudar sim
porque diminuindo o estress oxidativo
Vai facilitar a função das glândulas e
vai ajudar na suprarrenal nas gônadas
então de maneira indireta
Sim sim eu comentei aí na na exposição
Você tem razão
Sandra só que assim O óxido nítrico ele
pode ser um Radical Livre ruim também tá
ele é um sinalizador celular mas ele ele
pode ser um Radical Livre em algumas
circunstâncias
sim pode ajudar José dos Santos não é o
tratamento principal Mas pode
ajudar Olha sinceramente eu acho bem
interessante que o Douglas hor menes
esteja ensinando Mas se você tiver um
Pou de recurso Eu compraria eu não
tentaria fazer em casa a não ser que
você queira fazer como um hobby né um
passatempo Porque como é que você vai
ter certeza a não ser que você tenha um
medidor de orp em casa né que ficou
bacana isso daí né eu faria assim mais
com um projeto de ciência mas a partir
do momento que você tem um recurso
sobrando você compra um gerador e não
tente fazer em casa
tá é infelizmente Daiane né Doriane tem
muitos forne ores no Mercado Livre que
são complicados eu já tive problemas
desculpa com Aliexpress tem que tomar
muito cuidado ao comprar Aliexpress tem
muita coisa falsificada lá tá então eu
já tive problema já comprei produto
muito bom por lá e também produtos muito
ruins Então tem que tomar muito cuidado
com o
Aliexpress bem vamos continuar aqui vou
mudar o slide aqui tem como utilizar o
hidrogênio molecular uma forma direta e
eficaz de
administração usada principalmente em
ambientes clínicos é o inalatório né
você não vai conseguir fazer isso em
casa então eu recomendo que vocês usam o
item dois aí que é água enriquecida com
hidrogênio que é uma mod bem prática
acessível e ainda dá para fazer também
nas clínicas injeção intravenosa de
hidrogênio diluído em
Salina
bem então resumindo tudo que nós falamos
a água rica em hidrogênio apresenta um
potencial terapêutico significativo para
melhoria do metabolismo de lipídios e
glicose oferecendo então uma abordagem
inovadora e não invasiva pro manejo de
várias doenças metabólicas para promoção
de um estilo de vida mais saudável e
Esperamos que cada vez mais pesqu vão
surgindo e a gente possa ter mais
evidências para poder que isso seja uma
coisa mainstream que pelo menos o
hidrogênio se torne mainstream já que o
Houve essa barreira tão forte com o
ozônio vamos falar um pouquinho do
ozônio desculpa ozônio não do hidrogênio
molecular pra saúde da
pele a pele é uma superfície de contato
que nós temos que é muito importante PR
nossa saúde
então a saúde da pele a cicatrização de
feridas são aspectos muito importantes
da Medicina do bem-estar e a terapia com
água rica em hidrogênio tem mostrado
resultados bem promissores nesse Campo o
hidrogênio molecular pelas suas
propriedades antioxidantes
antiinflamatórias pode desempenhar um
papel
significativo na manutenção da saúde da
Pele na aceleração de qualquer processo
de C cataliza então estudos indicam que
hidrogênio pode reduzir o estresse
oxidativo na pele então é um fator
contribuinte pro envelhecimento cutâneo
já falando de novo aqui do ante
envelhecimento então usando hidrogênio
molecular você pode prevenir o
desenvolvimento de doenças na pele e
também prevenir o envelhecimento da
pele então no contexto de cicatrização
de feridas água rica em hidrogênio
desculpa a água rica em hidrogênio pode
melhorar a resposta inflamatória reduzir
o inchaço a vermelhidão estimular a
formação de vasos para cicatrização não
aquela formação de vasos para câncer né
que a angiogênese o processo de formação
de novos vasos
sanguíneos que no caso da cicatrização é
essencial pro fornecimento de nutrientes
e oxigênio paraa área afetada então o
androgênio tem sido associado à promoção
da proliferação das células que
recuperam a pele né que vão cicatrizar
que são os fibroblastos e também ajuda a
síntese de colágeno Isso vai ser
fundamental paraa estrutura e
resistência da pele para resultar uma
cicatrização mais rápida e eficaz então
aplicação tópica né na pele de água rica
em hidrogênio ou a inalação do gás
hidrogênio pode ter efeitos benéficos na
saúde da pele como a melhoria da
hidratação e a redução da aparência de
rugas isso se deve à capacidade de
penetração profunda do hidrogênio na
pele onde ele pode exercer os seus
efeitos antioxidantes a nível celular
protegendo as células da pele contra os
danos causados por radiação ultravioleta
poluição e vários outros fatores
ambientais então a terapia com
hidrogênio pode ser uma abordagem
inovadora paraa saúde da pele e a
cicatrização de feridas tem um grande
potencial para melhorar a qualidade de
vida e os resultados estéticos né
indivíduos que buscam tratamentos para
condições de P condições cutâneas ou que
estão se recuperando de lesões
então Regina pode ser utilizado
hidrogênio molecular no corte
pós-cirúrgico o hidrogênio não vai
reduzir o estresse emocional mas vai
ajudar
nas consequências do estresse né que o
estresse emocional vai promover Mais
stresse oxidativo também vai formar mais
radicais livres então o hidrogênio vai
ajudar
nisso Sim pode ser utilizado para
tratamento de nódulo de pulmão não para
curar Porque também tem que ser um
tratamento de suporte né então pode
ajudar no tratamento do no de pulmão
tireoide creio que não jazi aí seria
mais o caso do
oxigênio do ozônio porque o hidrogênio
ele ele é antioxidante ele não vai
danificar DNA de de vírus
beleza Que eu saiba não Cláudio o
hidrogênio não aumenta o GH que é o
hormônio do
crescimento Então já comentamos aqui
sobre a ingestão de água enriquecida de
hidrogênio que todos vocês podem fazer
em casa e o uso uso de inaladores de
hidrogênio que são feitos em
clínica então é totalmente seguro você
ingerir água enriquecida com hidrogênio
ã através desses positivos que dissolvem
o gás na
água pode ser bebido todos os dias
irregularmente
é uma maneira muito simples de você ter
os benefícios do hidrogênio
molecular e aí tem o uso inalado em
consultórios e clínicas por meio de
máquinas específicas porque o hidrogênio
em forma de gás hospitalar ele é
perigoso de você manusear que ele pode
explodir então tem esse
detalhe e quando você inala o gás
hidrogênio eh na faixa de 4% misturado
com oxigênio e outros gases ele vai
proporcionar uma via de administração
alternativa que pode ser bem útil em
condições de saúde
específicas
tá aqui perguntando se ajuda no
ressecamento vaginal
hum provavelmente não
Regina Talvez nos efeitos do
ressecamento né se se o ressecamento
provocou algum tipo de ferida aí vai
ajudar a cicatrizar mas para
ressecamento você vai ter que usar ou um
hidratante ou usar aí uma reposição
hormonal tem uns aparelhos vendidos no
Mercado Livre e no AliExpress eu não vou
indicar nenhum vendedor aqui agora no
momento tá você vai ter que fazer sua
pesquisa lá busque um vendedor que
seja com a boa reputação
é uma fonte confiável de
compra então é muito importante que
vocês busquem informações de produt
produtos de fontes confiáveis
falando um pouco sobre o o gás
hidrogênio inalado e tá sendo pesquisado
porque tem um grande potencial de
melhorar os resultados após uma parada
cardíaca teve um ensaio Clínico chamado
ensaio de inalação de hidrogênio para
pacientes após parada cardíaca fora do
hospital que está avaliando a eficácia
da inalação de
hidrogênio molecular em conjunto com a
terapia de hipotermia para recuperar
esse coração que teve uma parada
cardíaca então o gás hidrogênio ele
administrado adicionando a mistura de
gases usados na respiração
artificial dispositivos que foram
desenvolvidos no Japão na universidade
keo misturo hidrogênico de tanques de
alta pressão com ar mas isso requer uma
operação cuidadosa devido ao risco de
explosão do hidrogênio em concentrações
superiores a
4% Então já estão sendo desenvolvidas
ligas de armazenamento para serem mais
seguros você trabalhar com hidrogênio
isso a nível hospitalar e clínica né que
a liga de armazenamento Lan 5 ela pode
armazenar hidrogênio sob pressões
moderadas e liberar de forma segura para
uso
médico porque o armazenamento de manuse
do hidrogênio requer um controle de
qualidade rigoroso para garantir a
dosagem correta e evitar
contaminação também se utiliza o
hidrogênio diluído né em solução
Salina isso também pode ser feito a
nível de
[Música]
consultório logicamente você não vai
fazer isso em casa
vamos falar de alguns estudos aqui que
foi usado a água saturada com hidrogênio
que é o que você pode utilizar em casa
teve um estudo com ratos para tratamento
de diabetes e a concentração efetiva
mínima de hidrogênio foi de 10% de
saturação o que se traduziu Em 200 ml de
água hidrogenada saturada como parte da
ingestão deárea de 2 l para um ser
humano então baseado nesse estudo que
foi feito em ratos se sugere que você
ingira pelo menos 200 ml da água
hidrogenada dentro de uma ingestão de á
de 2 l por dia mas pode ser mais do que
isso também tá seria a dose mínima
eficaz
aqui Água de hidrogênio já está
disponível comercialmente e vendida em
farmácias e academi de ginástica no
Japão então no Japão tá mais evoluído em
relação a isso lá no Japão esses
produtos não são regul ados eh como
farmacêuticos e são utilizados como
suplementos em vez de tratamentos
médicos vamos vamos responder mais
perguntas
aqui não Eliseu não é recomendado você
deixar água hidrogenada há muito tempo
porque esse hidrogênio vai acabar sendo
eliminado dessa água tá é melhor você
beber logo em seguida depois da
geração certo pessoal então estamos indo
para 1 hora de Live acho que já respondi
quase todas as
perguntas
de novo Pessoal vocês vão ter que ir no
mercado livre vocês vão ter que ir no
AliExpress buscar um bom vendedor
dessas garrafas eu não vou indicar aqui
nenhum site específico nenhhum link
específico tá tem no Marketplace que é o
caso do Mercado Livre do
AliExpress
eh fabricantes no Brasil Regina eu não
conheço obrigado pelo comentário Adriano
então eu vou encerrar aqui com vocês
agradecer imensamente a presença de
todos vocês e assistam o vídeo novamente
é muito comum a pessoa entrar depois no
meio da Live E fazer perguntas que já
foram respondidas então assistam o vídeo
depois com calma mesmo que o vídeo tem
uma hora de duração vocês podem assistir
em pequenos trechos tá o próprio YouTube
Ele marca para você o ponto que você
parou então se você viu 15 minutos sai
da Live vai fazer outra coisa volta
naquele mesmo vídeo o YouTube lembra
onde você terminou de ver então você
continua a ver daquele ponto em diante
tá então isso é uma coisa que muitas
vezes eu vejo vídeos com 4 horas de
duração no YouTube e como é que eu
consigo ver eu vejo tudo uma vez não eu
vejo em pedaços então mesmo que o vídeo
seja longo se você tem interesse no
assunto vale a pena
assistir
Ok o José tá falando que tem fabricantes
no Brasil tá eu não
conheço então você pode tá indicando pro
pessoal aí José dos Santos
Ok bem pessoal até a próxima abraço para
vocês